[Musik]
norwegen die laut statistik eines der
glücklichsten länder der erde mit einer
florierenden wirtschaft und einer natur
die touristen in scharen anzieht
und mit den weltweit höchsten
marktanteil von elektroautos
im september wurden verkaufsrekorde
erzielt
was die hälfte der neuwagen
batteriebetrieb
der kampf gegen die luftverschmutzung
scheint in diesen breitengraden dem sieg
sehr nahe zu sein
in der hauptstadt gibt es mehr
schadstofffreie autos als in jedem
anderen teil des landes
[Musik]
das ist das stadtzentrum von oslo
und da wo mein freund zu dem später
gehen die wende in europa im westen
unter der oper und siehst du da drüben
werden viele neue häuser gebaut du bist
nicht im stadtzentrum aber trotzdem
ziemlich nah dran
[Musik]
und auf einem kleinen hügel nicht weit
von der altstadt von oslo ihr freund
lebt auf der anderen seite des feldes um
ihre liebesgeschichte zu leben musste
sie sich was einfallen lassen
wir sind ungefähr hier
innovative und mein freund lebt ich
würde sagen außerhalb der karte ich
glaube ist in ungefähr neun meilen
um mit meinem benzinauto hin und zurück
zu fahren müsste ich 78 kronen bezahlen
das sind fast acht euro
dann wurde mir klar dass ich mit meinem
elektroauto keine maut gebühren zahlen
muss
keine parkgebühren und kein geld für
benzin
und diesel die rechnung war für mich
also einfach zu machen und deshalb habe
ich mich für das e-auto entschieden
gurus wahl fiel auf einen gebrauchten
elektro-golf für dem sie die hälfte des
listenpreises bezahlte sie zeigt uns
voller stolz wie sie für die
energieversorgung ausgerüstet wir
im moment lade ich mein auto so auf
da drüben ist die steckdose an der wand
und hier sehen sie das kabel das mit dem
auto verbunden ist in zukunft werde ich
es an das gerät anschließen dass ich
gestern installiert habe
so kann ich meine batterien schneller
aufladen
was sie hier sehen ist langsames
aufladen es ist nicht das beste aber man
kann es auch so machen
[Musik]
es ist sehr angenehm zu fahren es ist
ein weiches fahrgefühl und natürlich ist
es eine automatik wagen man muss nicht
ständig schalten der die kampagne die
marching conti nationen
beschleunigung ist auch ziemlich gut
soll man jemanden überholen oder auf der
autobahn fahren will geht das mit diesem
auto besser ist mit einem benziner
ich fahre nicht jeden tag mit dem auto
zur arbeit weil ich mein fahrrad benutze
ich nehme ist um nachts aus zu gehen um
einzukaufen
es ist praktisch ein elektroauto zu
haben mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln braucht man mindestens
doppelt so lange für
eine fahrt zum supermarkt denn nur
wenige kilometer von ihrem zuhause
entfernt ist würde guru 50 kronen also
fast fünf euro ausgehen geld das sie nun
sparen kann ein sehr interessanter
vorteil denn in norwegen werden häufig
mord gebühren erhoben und zwar nicht nur
in der stadt sondern auch auf den
landstraßen
die diesel freiberufliche übersetzerin
haben viele norweger ihre autos mit
verbrennungsmotor ersetzt
angelockt durch die wirtschaftlichen
vorteile
wir überprüfen das indem wir zu einem
autohändler in der nähe von oslo ging wo
uns der besitzer erzählt dass 90 prozent
der autos die er verkauft elektrisch
sind das spitzenmodell hier ist der kia
soul
wir haben in diesem jahr mehr als 300
fahrzeuge verkauft bei einem
gesamtabsatz 600
und die kundentreue es gleich null wenn
sie das auto liefern können verkaufen
sondern das nicht in kurzer zeit schafft
suchen sie sich einen konkurrenten
aber wenn es um neue modelle geht sind
sie bereit zu warten
da der gesamte markt im internet ist
stellen sie ihre autos und lassen sich
in eine warteliste eintragen
derzeit haben schon rund 5000 menschen
den kia niro vorbestellt der erste
dezember auf den markt kommt
auch dieses paar erkundigte sich nach
dem elektrischen sanierung als wir mit
unserem interview fertig waren hatten
sie ihn bereits gebucht ohne ihn
überhaupt ausprobieren oder besichtigen
zu können da das auto noch nicht auf dem
markt um sich einen eindruck zu
verschaffen mussten die beiden auf
anraten des verkäufers einen blick auf
die hybrid version der gleichen marke
werfen
sie warten auf das neue modell
ja das ganz neue und warum weil er die
autonomie hat die wir brauchen
so einfach ist das
ja
ich glaube er sagte dass der kia nach
dem neuen sehr streng parametern eine
autonomie von 301 mylan hat dass es
reicht aus
vorher gab es modelle mit einer
autonomie von 124 meilen damit kommt man
ja nicht mal bis zu unserer berg hätte
ein elektroauto zu verkaufen ist
eigentlich keine aufgabe für ein
verkäufer der kunde ist einfach jeder
hat sich schon entschieden bevor er zu
uns in den laden kommt
das hat uns erstaunt in der schweiz ist
der kauf eines autos die zweitgrößte
investition nach einem haus man überlegt
und vergleicht die modelle warum greifen
die norweger einfach so zu
es gibt keine steuern auf elektroautos 0
deshalb ist bist so erschwinglich sie
können ein luxusauto zu einem
vernünftigen preis haben
es ist das teuerste aber es ist nicht
elektrisch
das ist ein diesel und hier sehen sie
den preis des wagens etwa 78.000 euro
und die kfz steuern liegen bei fast
30.000 euro es sind etwa 40 prozent der
gesamtkosten an steuern für den
norwegischen staat
das entspricht einer hohen steuer von
mehr als 37.000 schweizer franken nicht
gerade peanuts
die rolle der regierung ist in norwegen
von grundlegender bedeutung
zusammen mit dem parlament kann sie
natürlich entscheiden welche fahrzeuge
wie in den nächsten jahren fahren werden
jetzt wollen sie nicht mehr dass wir
diesen autos kaufen sondern elektroautos
[Musik]
an dieser stelle wollen wir verstehen
wie das norwegische system funktioniert
wir gehen zum verband für elektroautos
einer gemeinnützigen organisation die
60.000 verbraucher vertritt
[Musik]
es ist eine politik von zuckerbrot und
peitsche die verbrenner werden mit hohen
steuern und hohen abgaben belegt für
emissionsfreie autos muss man nichts
davon bezahlen und man hat noch andere
vorteile zum beispiel darf man die
busspuren benutzen
die wichtigsten anreize sind steuerliche
art politisch gerne keine mehrwertsteuer
und keine ein vorsteuer beim kauf machen
den preis von e-autos wettbewerbsfähig
auch der wegfall der
straßenbenutzungsgebühren ist ein
wichtiger anreiz und zwar auf lokaler
ebene
peter haubner land hat uns ein konkretes
beispiel gezeigt im high end segment ist
der importpreis eines elektroautos in
norwegen fast doppelt so hoch wie der
des selben autos mit verbrennungsmotor
aber letztendlich kostet das elektroauto
weniger weil es nicht besteuert wird das
beispiel von tesla ist nicht zufällig
gewählt im vergangenen september war
fast jeder fünfte neuwagen auf dem markt
ein e-auto des amerikanischen
unternehmens
ist es für sie normal so aufzuladen
natürlich
arbeite
ich komme jeden tag hier hören zu
arbeiten und dies ist einer der orte an
denen ich auftanken kann und es ist hier
kostenlos und man kann drei stunden
bleiben also okay ich zur arbeit kommen
dann zurück um es zu holen
dieser fahrer verrät uns ein weiteres
argument für das elektro auto
parken und öffentliches aufladen sind
kostenlos auch um denjenigen entgegen zu
kommen die in einer wohnung leben und
keine möglichkeit haben eine auf
ladevorrichtung zu installieren die in
norwegen verwendete energie besteht zu
99 prozent aus wasserkraft ist also
sauber
wir fahren nach eggenberg einem
wohnviertel von oslo in jedem zweiten
stadthaus gibt es elektroautos amelia
und robert haben sogar je 1
[Musik]
wir haben im zentrum gewohnt dann sind
wir hoch gezogen wir mussten in die
stadt fahren um die kinder zum
kindergarten zu bringen und abzuholen
ich habe es mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln versucht aber das war
wirklich schwierig ich hatte ein baby im
kinderwagen 1 auf dem rücken und 1 lief
nebenher
es war wirklich schwierig zur
hauptverkehrszeit in die straßenbahn und
die u bahn zu kommen
[Musik]
es ist nicht einfach im stadtzentrum
einen parkplatz zu finden während es für
elektroautos kostenlose parkplätze gibt
also beschlossen wir ein e auto zu
kaufen
[Musik]
amelia eine gewerkschaftsführerin ging
voran ihr mann horvath ein manager in
einem großen unternehmen folgte diesem
beispiel
[Musik]
ich habe mir ausgerechnet dass mich ein
elektroauto einen tesla und mein altes
auto mit fossilen brennstoffen in den
nächsten zehn jahren monatlich das
gleiche kosten würden
da war seine leichte entscheidung den
alten benziner zu verkaufen und einen
neuen tesla zu holen
das problem ist dass er mir ein bisschen
zu auffällig erscheint ich mag es nicht
damit zu fahren
[Musik]
ja es ist ein großes auto lang und breit
und hat einen bestimmten stil
also entweder man liebt es oder man
hasst es
[Musik]
in norwegen sagt horvath hat es schon
paradoxe effekt dass elektroautos zum
preis eines mittelklassewagens aber mit
höhere autonomie
kreatur effektiv paradox da liegt die
nachfrage nach diesen modellen ist so
groß dass die wartezeiten inzwischen
explodiert sind und bei zwei jahren
legen wer also sein auto gerade erst
bekommen hat kann es zu einem noch
höheren preis als dem listenpreis weiter
verkaufen und dabei ein drittel des
wertes erzielen
[Musik]
wenn man sich erst einmal an das fahren
eines elektroautos gewöhnt hat ist die
rückkehr zu autos mit fossilen
brennstoffen wie eine rückkehr in die
steinzeit
wenn man dann noch im dichten verkehr
steht und die emissionen der autos vor
sich sieht fühlt man sich gut weil man
weiß dass man die umwelt nicht belastet
seit den späten 90er jahre haben die
verschiedenen koalitionen die in dem
skandinavischen land regiert haben alle
das steuererleichterung programm
zugunsten von elektrofahrzeugen
unterstützt das paradoxe daran ist dass
diese strategie auch dank des erdöls
möglich war das in den 60er jahren in
der nordsee entdeckt wurde mit der
ausbeutung der vorkommen des schwarzen
goldes und dank kluger investitionen hat
norwegen den größten staatsfonds der
welt gebildet wir sprechen hier von über
1000 milliarden dollar noch wohin
steuert oslo mit seiner öko fördern
[Musik]
das parlament hat beschlossen das bis
20.25 jedes neue auto emissionsfrei sein
muss
und an diesem punkt muss die industrie
liefern
das ist es in diesem fall nicht ein
bisschen heuchlerisch weiterhin öl zu
verkaufen
was ich sagen kann ist dass wir noch ein
paar jahre lang nicht nur als treibstoff
den verkehr sondern auch in anderen
bereichen
wir versuchen auch sicherzustellen dass
die förderplattform erneuerbare energie
nutzen von
innovabee und wir versuchen den
schadstoffausstoß der plattform zu
minimieren
norwegen ist auch ein öl produzieren das
land
und das wird es auch in den kommenden
jahren sein
morgens um 7 uhr 30 einfach die stadt
wir steigen in einen bus zwischen dem
zentrum und den außenbezirken von oslo
verkehrt
[Musik]
im quartier gibt es elektroautos die uns
auf der busspur behindern
es ist rush hour und mit der starken
zunahme von elektroautos gibt es mehr
verkehr
sie mussten also ihre fahrpläne
unser zeitplan berücksichtigt das jetzt
wir haben immer 30 40 minuten pause
bevor wir wieder zur schicht gehen wenn
man die kommentare
so haben unsere manager das problem
gelöst
aber ich weiß nicht wie es die fahrgäste
machen werden
[Musik]
laut vorschrift müssen in jedem
elektroauto mindestens zwei personen
sitzen wenn sie die busspur benutzen
wollen sarkozy muss
ich hoffe dass sich die situation
dadurch ein bisschen verbessert
die zunahme von elektroautos die den
busfahrern das leben schwer machen trägt
dazu bei die durch den verkehr
verursachte umweltverschmutzung zu
verringern
eine unsichtbare verschmutzung die aber
zu bestimmten zeiten des jahres große
probleme verursacht
wie sie sehen können ist die stadt von
vielen hügeln umgeben nicoline und wenn
es windstill und im winter sehr kalt ist
sind die unteren luftschichten wärmer
als die oberen
dadurch entsteht eine art decke über der
stadt dadurch wird das problem der
luftverschmutzung sehr ernst
im vergangenen jahr starben mindestens
186 menschen vorzeitig an den folgen der
lokalen luftverschmutzung außer der
linken alle lokale und das muss gestoppt
werden wir versuchen die co2 emissionen
innerhalb von zehn jahren um 95 prozent
zu reduzieren
ein ziemlich ehrgeiziges ziel und wenn
wir es erreichen wollen müssen wir beim
verkehr anfangen denn in oslo werden 61
prozent der umweltverschmutzung durch
den verkehr verursacht
wir gehen zum fuße des schlosses von
akkus einer mittelalterlichen festung
die zur verteidigung der stadt errichtet
aber nie erobert wurde und heute einer
der wichtigsten touristenattraktionen
ist aber was uns heute interessiert ist
er unter gründet
wir befinden uns hier auf dem
wahrscheinlich ersten parkplatz der welt
der für elektro autos reserviert ist es
handelt sich um einen alten
luftschutzbunker aus dem kalten krieg
früher schützte er uns vor der invasion
schwedische und dänische verfahren und
heute dient dem umweltschutz
[Musik]
79 parkplätze und ein stilles kommen und
gehen die polizei kommt um zu
kontrollieren und strafzettel zu
verteilen wenn die autos nicht korrekt
geparkt können sie sich einen so großen
kostenlosen parkplatz vorstellen nun es
ist nicht mal der einzige
[Musik]
die herausforderung für die ladestation
besteht darin mit der zunahme der
elektrofahrzeuge schritt zu halten jedes
jahr um über 100 prozent steigt in den
nächsten drei jahren werden wir die
anzahl der ladestation verdreifachen für
mich sowohl in parkhäusern wie diesem
als auch an den straßen
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt 1300 kostenlose
ladestationen und in drei jahren werden
wir 3100 haben
wenn viel mehr elektroautos im umlauf
sind wird es eines tages möglich sein
für das aufladen zu bezahlen
es wird immer noch viel billiger sein
als benzin aber wir werden das
investierte geld zurückbekommen
der leiter der stadt oslo ist überzeugt
in nicht allzu ferner zukunft wenn
elektroautos die mehrheit ausmachen
werden sie auch steuerbefreiungen und
andere privilegien verzichten
mehrere stadtverwaltungen auch die von
oslo haben schon beschlossen dass im
nächsten jahr neue und höhere
straßenbenutzungsgebühren eingeführt
werden
und zum ersten mal werden auch
elektroautos zahlen müssen wenn auch zu
reduzierten satz
denn das geld wird für die
instandhaltung und den bau neuer straßen
benötigt die auch von emissionsfreien
fahrzeugen genutzt werden
aber einige leute haben das nicht gut
aufgelegt die norweger die an hohe
steuern gewöhnt sind und dazu neigen die
behörden zu respektieren gingen auf die
straße und protestierten unter dem motto
es reicht und keine neuen straßen
gebühren
mit der verbesserung der technologie und
dem anstieg ihres marktanteils ist es
klar dass auch elektro autos besteuert
werden müssen
wir sind aber der meinung dass es zu
früh wäre jetzt damit zu beginnen weil
dies das erreichen des ziels gefährden
könnte bis 2025 nur noch elektroautos
zuzulassen
schon jetzt gibt es in oslo anzeichen
dafür dass es nicht mehr so sein wird
wie früher
wie kommt es dass der parkplatz für
elektroautos verschwunden
wir haben ähnlich gefunden und waren
überrascht ist er auf google maps ist er
noch da es ist eine politische
entscheidung um zu viele autos im
zentrum von oslo zu vermeiden
[Musik]
bis ende des jahres sollen alle autos
aus dem zentrum verschwunden
ohne ausnahme ziel ist es dass die
bürger die straßen und plätze zurück
erobern
dank mehr öffentlicher verkehrsmittel
und mehr fahrradwege nur noch die
elektrischen lieferwagen der händler und
handwerker werden in oslo unterwegs sein
wie auf die behinderten beförderung und
die pferde der polizisten
[Musik]
okay die norwegische hauptstadt ist also
spitzenklasse aber was ist mit dem rest
des landes
letzter halt wir besuchen eine familie
aus so einer kleinen stadt 31 meilen
südlich von oslo hier gibt es kein chaos
sondern dass norwegen dass man erwartet
ein fjord mit einem kleinen hafen ein
ruhiges leben
[Musik]
ich bin arzt und auch wenn wir nicht in
oslo leben gibt es immer noch einige
mautgebühren
[Musik]
am anfang als ich zur arbeit gependelt
bin war die fahrt ziemlich lang
mit dem elektroauto konnte ich die
busspur benutzen das bedeutete eine
halbe stunde mehr zeit mit meiner
familie und weniger zeit bei der arbeit
oder im stau
[Musik]
das ist ein fantastisches gefühl muss
ich zugeben aber
jetzt haben viele leute ein elektroauto
so dass die möglichkeiten etwas
eingeschränkt waren vor allem in oslo
aber es ist trotzdem ein vorteil
als wir merkten wie sehr es uns gefällt
haben wir das zweite gekauft
wir hatten also zwei elektroautos und
immer noch das große diesel auto
wir dachten wenn wir lange
familienausflüge zu freunden oder im
winter zu unserer hütte machen wollen
bräuchten wir es für die langen fahrten
ich glaube in den letzten vier jahren
haben wir es nur einmal benutzt um weit
weg zu fahren
ich glaube dass wir ihn irgendwann
verkaufen werden weil wir ein
elektroauto mit ähnlichen eigenschaften
und ungefähr der gleichen autonomie
nehmen werden und wir dann keinen diesel
mehr brauchen diese
das beispiel norwegen zeigt dass die
regierung mit einer gezielten politik
wichtige ziele im kampf gegen die
luftverschmutzung errechnet haben
oslo bietet keine bargeld hilfen sondern
verzichtet auf große steuerbelastungen
für elektroautos ein erfolg der enden
wird wenn die vorteile verschwinden
die frage ist hätten wir ein elektroauto
gekauft wenn sie uns keinen vorteil
geboten hätten die antwort lautet nein
auf keinen fall die zweite frage ist sie
wenn sie uns morgen alle privilegien
wegnehmen würden würden wir dann ein
auto kaufen jetzt wo wir es schon
gefahren sind allerdings kost eindeutig
ja
damit die menschen das neue zu schätzen
wissen müssen ihnen sofort
erleichterungen angeboten werden das ist
der grund warum sich das phänomen in
europa nicht durchsetzt weil es keine
anfangs vorteile gibt
[Musik]
in norwegen gab es 2017 rund 142 1000
elektroautos das sind 53 prozent des
fahrzeugbestandes
in der schweiz waren 2017 rund 14.000
elektroautos im umlauf das sind 0,3
prozent der fahrzeugflotte in der
schweiz gibt es keine kaufanreize
[Musik]